Speaker 1: Very interesting. New poll shows
that the MAGA movement is wildly unpopular,
really unpopular. One of the few things less
popular than Donald Trump himself is the MAGA
movement. Just 24% of Americans surveyed have
positive views of the Make America Great Again
movement in a new national NBC News poll. This
is a very interesting poll because it actually
surveys people about a number of other issues. So,
for example, if you look at Black Lives Matter,
40% negative, 38% positive. That's a net
rating of minus two. Now, you might say,
wow, BLM is really unpopular in the United
States. Well, it's far less unpopular than
everything else in the poll. Joe Biden's net
rating, the Democratic Party's net rating,
the Republican Party's net rating are all
minus ten, meaning by a ten point margin,
they are seen more negatively than positively.
More unpopular than Biden, the Democratic Party
and the Republican Party is Donald Trump. Donald
Trump has a net rating of -19 34% positive,
53% negative. And then even worse than that is
the MAGA movement, where only 24% of Americans
see MAGA positively and 45 negative. That's
-21 net favorability. Now one of the. Really
interesting things, strange concerning about
America things, is that despite Trump being
very unpopular and MAGA being even more unpopular,
Trump and his MAGA movement are currently easily
the 2024 Republican frontrunners. And
Trump, if he becomes the 2024 nominee,
could easily win in 2020 for the general election.
He almost did win in 2020, even though it was an 8
million vote margin and a very solid popular vote
win for Joe Biden. One of the biggest, in fact,
when you look at the Electoral College system that
we have, it didn't it would not have taken that
much of a shift in just a handful of states, three
states really to turn the election towards Donald
Trump. Now, there is another important question
when you ask people about favorability and
opinions. Just because moderate Republicans and
centrists, for example, don't like the MAGA label
or everything that MAGA stands for doesn't mean
they won't vote for Trump anyway. There is a huge
difference. There's a canyon between I don't like
Trump and I'd vote for a Democrat like Joe Biden.
Those are two very, very different things. Trump
got 74 million votes in 2020. These were not just
the fringe and extremists of the Republican Party.
We have to understand this on the left. Yes, MAGA
is not particularly well liked. Many Republicans
don't like Trump. Low favorability. All of it is
true. But when you get 74 million votes, it's not
just the fringe extremists from your party. There
were self-described centrists who really didn't
like Joe Biden. There were moderates. There were
so on and so forth. So it's very plausible that
if Trump makes the same failed promises again,
I'll bring back jobs. We're going to get $2 a
gallon gas. We're going to replace Obamacare with
something beautiful. OBAMA Whatever promises, many
of these people are going to fall for it again,
even if it doesn't make a damn bit of sense.
So MAGA not popular, could still win in 2024.